this is a Fox News Alert just moments
ago the office of the Special Counsel
Robert Muller denied a report that ran
last night in BuzzFeed that story said
that President Trump had ordered Michael
Cohen to lie to Congress the story set
off a full day of speculation in
Washington for members of Congress and
the media that impeachment and
indictment might be imminent now to
repeat the special counsel is denying
the substance of that story good evening
and welcome to Tucker Carlson tonight
this is moving very fast a remarkable
day trace Gallagher has more on what is
happening trace and this really is the
bombshell Tucker because breaking right
now is you said robert muller special
counsel a spokesperson has knocked down
this BuzzFeed report quoting now
BuzzFeed's description of specific
statements to the special counsels
office and characterization of documents
and testimony obtained by this office
regarding Michael Cohen's congressional
testimony are not accurate that is
critical because remember the BuzzFeed
report lay this at the door of the
special counsel saying quoting again the
special counsel's office learned about
Trump's directive for Cohen to lie to
Congress through interviews with
multiple witnesses from the Trump
Organization and internal company emails
text messages and a cache of other
documents but one of the reporters who
wrote the piece admitted he never saw
the alleged damning documents but he
still maintained that his reporting was
rock-solid listen to him
I am rock-solid my sourcing on this goes
beyond the two that are on the record
this 100% happened yeah 100% except
president Trump says it 100% didn't
happen tweeting quote lying to reduce
jail time clearly referencing Michael
Cohen's three-year prison sentence White
House deputy press secretary Hogan
giddily added this comment much
this is absolutely absolutely ludicrous
that we are giving any type of credence
or credibility to a news outlet like
BuzzFeed and he's right BuzzFeed does
have credibility issues including
multiple accusations of plagiarizing and
stealing original content a Pew Research
survey also found the publication to be
unreliable and of course BuzzFeed
published the uncorroborated and
salacious steal dossier which was
labeled and unverified smear of
President Trump even Democrats eager to
impeach the president had to qualify
their comments today saying if the
information is true watch you don't know
whether the new report about Cohen being
told the lie by the president is true or
not
ask mr. Cohen that yeah Cohen is
supposed to go back before Congress next
month but his legal adviser Lanny Davis
says he might be having second thoughts
about that remember 24 hours after
BuzzFeed broke this story
nobody matched the reporting and now we
know it's because it wasn't true
sucker it's just unbelievable just
unbelievable if you've been by a
television today you have seen a level
of frothy hysteria that really I've
never seen in 25 years of watching trace
Gallagher thank you very much Annie
McCarthy is a contributing editor at
National Review he's the former chief
assistant US attorney in New York and he
joins us tonight
Annie McCarthy this is not I mean I
think most of us were at least taking
seriously the possibility that this
story was rooted in fact now the special
counsels office which has commented on
virtually nothing for the past two years
is knocking it down what is your
reaction to this well I think the most
important thing Tucker is the money
paragraph of the of the BuzzFeed story
is the one that trace Gallagher honed in
on and the reason that's important is
because what what the Trump response to
this if there were any credibility to it
would want to be
is that you can't believe anything that
cohen says because he's a pervasive
serial liar but the way this story was
teed up it was that Muller had developed
independent information right and
corroborated it pieced it together
himself and then he confronted Cohen on
it not it's not a thing where you know
Cohen is peddling this information so
that if I were the white house that
would have been the part that would have
alarmed me the most and that's the part
that it appears that that Muller has
blown up I think the big hesitation that
those of us who watch this sort of thing
and did this sort of work prosecutor
work for for a living also couldn't get
our brains wrapped around is that what a
prosecutor would normally do if he
thought that there was a conspiracy
between Trump and Cohen to lie to
Congress is you would have Cohen plead
guilty to conspiracy to obstruct a
congressional investigation and then
have him in court when the judge asks
what did you do that makes you guilty
say I was involved in this conspiracy
with the president he told me to lie to
Congress and I went on ahead and did it
exactly you didn't see anything like
that in the charges against Cohen so
where could this story have come from do
you think I mean by my reading of it and
it was parts of it were unclear by
design but it left the impression that
this was an allegation directly from the
office of the Special Counsel you know
what do you make yeah where do you think
this information came from yeah the word
that started struck out is stuck out to
me Tucker when I read this was the word
and hardly oddly enough that they say at
the beginning of the story that the two
sources are connected to an
investigation of Cohen which made it
elusive whether they were talking about
the investigation of Cohen meaning the
special counsels investigation so you
don't know coming away from this are
these a couple of guys who you know are
in the loop enough to get briefed on law
enforcement investigations but are not
in the core of
Mahler's team it's very hard to to make
a judgement about that but I can only
tell you from you know I I was fortunate
enough as a prosecutor to work on a
couple of cases that were pretty
high-profile cases and if you asked the
number of people who now would say to
you that they worked on those cases and
where the case agent on the case there's
probably more people who would say it
then were you know then saw Bobby
Thompson's home run it was an awful lot
of people said no it's a say they had
lots of information yeah right it's like
there were 15 million people who claimed
to have been at Woodstock why would why
would the special counsel's office weigh
in on this tonight in the way that it
did I'm really pleased that they did I
think that it probably this is the sort
of thing that could really compromise
the president's ability to govern I
think a lot of us who have been troubled
by this investigation from the beginning
think that there's been too much
deference to investigative secrecy and
not enough acknowledgement that when you
have a Special Counsel investigation it
really makes it very difficult for the
President to govern the country